if I had to pick one song that sums up  my personality it would be it would be  Chan Chan of Buena Vista Social Club the  best advice a boss ever gave me was shut  up my best friend is my cellphone all  your friends are on in your phone so  life is horrible today no I usually  drown my sorrows by just being alone  being alone so without your best friend  the cell phone by a television character  I would be Krusty the Klown in the same  sense you know he's really sad behind  his face you know what I mean there is  something really sad and something  really yeah he's a bit weird one piece  of advice that give my 16 year old self  is stop wearing too large clothes  because it doesn't fit to you company  definitely when I'm not around and  people talk about me I hope they say  he's an imbecile why he's ridiculous or  he's a dumbass yeah